this is how you become a Rainmaker it
takes 20 hours to learn most things but
most people spend years delaying the
first hour don't be that person first
Google how to run a Facebook lead ad
this is how you're going to get leads
give something away for free the crazy
guarantee and you'll get leads your
skill will be upselling them into
something more expensive that's number
one Facebook lead ad you just Google how
to run one number two Google zapier
Facebook lead ad to Google Sheets this
will give you a makeshift CRM this will
just give you a big old list of leads
third Google zapier SMS notification
setup so that you can get notified
whenever you get a new lead you can call
them and text them that's it that's the
tech setup to make this work and I get
asked all the time on podcasts Etc if
you lost it all what would you do I've
lost it all twice I know exactly what I
would do this is what I did and this is
what I fell back on when I lost
everything if you're wondering how do I
figure out what offer to sell and what
service go to a business that's local
that sells expensive stuff offer to sit
at the front desk and try out a few
different offers until you get the one
that works